the Joe Rogan experience tell me about
this audible doing audible is an amazing
partner of mine now my first book I
can't make this up life lessons was a
New York Times number-one bestseller and
I got bit I got bit by the bug Wow as an
author I wanted to write a book I did it
look at the success that it had the
opportunity came up for me to voice that
book on audible and the audible success
was just as good if not greater than my
hardcover and people loved the fact that
the stories were real but hearing my
voice and hearing me be personable while
being real was a bonus from other things
and they've ever had the privilege of
listening to so I said I want to do
another one man but I'm big on this
motivation self-help inspiration thing
I'm really big on trying to do my part
so as I was telling you earlier I said
in my life man I got so so many stories
of all of my twists and turns and right
moves and wrong moves and decision
making that enhanced those moves or that
devalue them and made them incorrect
ultimately if I were to give information
it's just to open up people eyes is to
open up your eyes to to the reality of
you competing with you I want people to
understand that we lose because we are
ok with ignoring our faults right it's
not until you can accept your faults
your [ __ ] that you can grow and do
better we point the finger a lot by we
myself included I'm an example of it yo
I didn't do that because nobody told me
I didn't get up I didn't hear the alarm
why don't you call me and get me up
yeah I didn't know he was gonna go eat
didn't already tell me he's gonna go eat
I woulda came to eat but yawning tell me
I know we had a test today why don't you
tell me how to test day I didn't study
because anybody reached out to tell me
there's so many things that we place the
blame on others for that are truly our
responsibility and it becomes a habit
it's a force of habit so it's not as you
break that habit that you can do bigger
and better [ __ ]
so this audible original of mine called
the decision is about making you look at
[ __ ] differently making you realize the
tone of today and making you understand
how much you're a part of it I got a big
thing on social media near where I'm
like social medias mindfuck people and
to people now thinking that it's what
the world thinks social media has
mindfuck people into thinking that the
comments below a post or what the world
must be feeling and thinking about you
the insecurity levels have raised to an
all-time high because my belief is now I
posted something people are saying these
things underneath I don't want to go
outside because this is how they feel
mmm so I've now put this [ __ ] in my head
that as soon as I walk outside if you
look at me you talk about my posts ain't
you what pokes [ __ ] your tongue mouth
right you stop my post didn't you that's
why you're looking at me like that
I don't we need what we now think that
this is the way of the world right and
we're so engulfed into it that the
negative is so loud that you don't even
see the positive even if it's
overwhelmingly positive and a few
negative you don't see it the
concentrators negative you don't see it
yeah there was a black billionaire that
paid off student loans it was a story
for about a day and a half another story
popped up a reality star suck somebody
dick in the bath and it went on for
three weeks it was [ __ ] crazy news
it's breakin [ __ ] news
what that's all over the place the
reason why is because we spread the
negative as people we've fallen in love
with bad information and bad
no we're intrigued by it what's a
natural human instinct because those are
the things that can kill you like from
though the days when we were you know
living in small villages worried about
animals attacking us you had to be
always worried about negative negative
is the thing you had to concentrate on
cuz that could take your life positive
was something that's great that's good
and all but really got to concentrate on
negative and unfortunately that human
instinct is carried over into this time
where we don't really have the same fear
of danger that we had before for the
most part but we still concentrate on
these negative things we still
concentrate on negative comments
negative stories these negative things
carry more weight because we have a
natural inclination to keep an eye out
for danger it's a it's like our human
reward system's been hijacked it's been
hijacked by social media this new thing
that we're not prepared for reading
anonymous written things that are
negative in the [ __ ] and you know
there's a book called the coddling of
the American mind by Jonathan hate and
he wrote about this with children about
how many especially girls so many girls
are experiencing super high levels of
self-harm suicide and depression all
because of social media because they're
writing things and their friends are
commenting on them and people are
anonymous is saying you stupid fat [ __ ]
and who [ __ ] with their head in a way
that other generations before didn't
have to deal with before social media
there was nothing that could affect them
in this way and and you know stuff
because there's gifts and there's curses
to it of course like there's a there's
an amazing benefit behind it and of
course now we're seeing the you know the
bad within it so what I encourage any
and everybody to do is just understand
who you are truly understand who you are
learn yourself yeah learn yourself learn
your pros and cons get your flaws get
them out the way but with you not nobody
else nobody this is a you and you thing
of the [ __ ] that you know you need to
work on I'm telling you people when you
really look yourself in a mirror and use
start to pick yourself apart by yourself
yeah there's only room for improvement
it's easy to ignore your [ __ ] also
other people can't tell you things you
don't already know [ __ ] yeah
you're a thousand percent right yeah
you're a thousand percent right and it's
that's what this is my my audio book is
not a live like me tutorial it's not a
do what I did tutorial it's I would
never do that
because I don't have all the answers all
I have is stories and information that
you can now be privy to that can allow
you to make different [ __ ] turns on
his road of life
[Applause]